we're going to begin this hour with a
revealing first-hand account of what
happened inside the white house while
former president donald trump was in
office all of it according to former
secretary of defense mark esper he's got
a new book it's called a sacred oath
memoirs of a secretary of defense during
extraordinary times and it's a detailed
account of the nearly 18 months he
served under president trump from june
2019 to november of 2020. the former
secretary writes about the challenges of
working for trump including allegations
that the president suggested shooting at
protesters in the nation's capital
secretary esper joins us for his first
live television interview about this
book mr secretary thank you for being
here thanks great to be here uh i'm glad
you wrote the book i'm glad you served
in your role but i have to start with
kind of a process question which is why
did you accept this job in the first
place having just seen how president
trump treated your predecessor general
mattis you know i served my country
since the age of 18 when i went to west
point
10 years in the army active duty combat
gulf war another 11 years in the garden
reserve it was another chance for me to
once again serve my country in a way
that i thought could be meaningful and
help deliver on our nation's security
clearly it was meaningful as you write
in the book you had to stop a lot of bad
things from happening i i'd love to know
if there was a particular moment a high
point or really a low point where you
felt like the world order as we know it
or the country as we know it was in
danger of spinning out of control well
as i talk about my book it's june 1st
right we go from june 1st to june 2nd
protests around the country hundreds of
cities unrest the president is pushing
to call on active duty troops it is not
relenting and as we roll into june 3rd i
decide the night of june 2nd that i got
to get out there and say something the
republic feels wobbly
somebody needs to put you know their
hand on the wheel foot on the brake and
kind of calm things down and i thought
that me coming out publicly and saying
look i do not support invocation the
insurrection act it doesn't make sense
at this point in time that that might
help and i and i believe it did frankly
do you think that president trump fully
understood the consequences of his
actions when he was in office
with regard to this no he was just so
upset and angry about the protest in the
street that he wanted to suppress it he
wanted to get it under control you also
wrote
that president trump asked the military
if he could shoot missiles into mexico
um and you basically explained to him
that that's illegal it's an act of war
right and he said well we'll shoot those
missiles at cartels and and drug houses
um when you told him that what was his
response well look yeah he wanted to
shoot at drug labs and as i say i get it
right we we all are troubled by drugs in
america he was trying to find a way to
go after this but there are right ways
to do it and wrong ways to do it and
when i said no you can't it would be an
act of war illegal he said well look
nobody will know we they just won't find
out wow
in your book that um you wrote here you
said that our nation's institutions and
our democracy are only as strong as the
people who are serving in those roles
it's likely
that former president trump will run
again in 2024.
what are the consequences of him running
and possibly being nominated
as the next president of the united
states i'm glad you read that and
highlighted that and you're right i
think our institutions are only as
strong as the people in them i was
blessed to serve with wonderful people
to pentagon who really put country first
and so that's one of the things you have
to look at when you elect the president
who who will they bring in around them
who will be in their cabinet and i think
this is in some ways a cautionary tale
about what the future may hold if
president trump runs in 2024. what is at
stake i mean here we are talking about
ukraine um we're still always you know
keeping a close eye on china iran but
what is at stake
if president trump were to run again
well my view is whoever runs has to put
country first over self you have to have
integrity principles you have to be
willing to reach across the aisle and
advance the country's greater good and
president trump doesn't make those marks
for me so we have to be very cautious
about who he elect to be president is he
competent enough to hold office
he's held office but i would say for all
the republicans like myself who were
attracted to the policies he advanced
less regulation lower taxes a stronger
military and so on there's a whole other
crew of republicans out there who
advance those same principles without
the turmoil without the bitterness and
divisiveness and the courses that donald
trump brings like who well i'm not going
to start naming names today we'll see
the the 2024 will start after the
midterms right let's see who merges
let's see who who will who will find
some distance between them and donald
trump yeah
what does it say about the state of
politics in this country that after your
experience with president trump in the
2020 election you could not bring
yourself to
vote for president biden
well it's uh look i i work with
president biden if you will when i was
served on a senate foreign relations
committee i know who he is what he was i
i think we should have better choices
out there than what we have today out of
a nation of 330 million people we've got
to have a better set of candidates to
really help lead our country and they
have to put country first they have to
aspire to greater things do you have any
interest
i couldn't win an election i'm i'm too
much in the middle i guess i i think you
know i consider myself a reagan
republican in the book you talk about
how president trump is unprincipled uh
hearing you say that you think he's also
unfit i think is a new line that you've
crossed here and i i'm curious
you know you're going to get involved
now with the publication of this book
with a kind of tit-for-tat back and
forth with the former president so for
example he'd no commented on the
shooting missiles into mexico uh but he
says it's a lie that he suggested
shooting protesters in washington in
that fateful summer what's your response
to that people will choose to believe
who they want to believe i will tell you
that i sent this my my draft out to over
two dozen
four-star officers senior civilians even
a few cabinet members to review nearly
all or parts of the book and to get it
it helped me get it as accurate complete
and fair as possible so one of one of
the four no's that you and mark milley
had when you were trying to hold order
there in the administration was you
didn't want to politicize the department
of defense i remember speaking to
general mattis about his book when it
came out he was also not wanting to do
that your book seems to go further now
in this interview you're going further
are you worried with the book and with
your statements that you risk
politicizing the very department you
wanted to protect well look i'm clearly
i'm out of office now i was a political
appointee so there is some expectation
that you have one foot in the political
camp and one foot outside the political
camp but i'll tell you what the
department of defense has a strong ethos
it's a it's a resilient organization
we're blessed to have the the service
members
officer nco enlisted members serving
that we do i think the the institution
will endure it's for 240 some years it's
been defending america
it will endure quickly uh what is your
thoughts on the biden administration's
approach on the war in ukraine well as i
said i think it was mixed at first i
thought they were moving too slowly and
not enough i i said from day one we
should implement full sanctions and give
the ukrainians everything they need to
do the job but i think it's picked up i
think the president has done a good job
in terms of bringing along the allies i
think very good job in terms of the
strategic release of information to
reveal what putin was trying to do
surreptitiously so i think we're in a
much better spot today than where we
were initially all right secretary esper
as you put in the very front of the book
the oath of the secretary of defense is
to the constitution most important thing
thank you very much thank you all very
much thank you the book a sacred oath
goes on sale tomorrow